я просто дієти раз і поза політикою
Для важливого процесу варила нами не
саміті у німецькому ганновері
обама то європейські лідери он і ви
загадали свою bespeco впали тільки в
рамках на тому випадку не штати на youtube
вигляд провела свої виринайте п'ятого
покоління двадцять два тому з свинячий
європейські союзники в альянсі ти маша
україна місяць лиж і в контексті
виконання мінських догляд буду артем
та ноги та wrap залишалося та легко важливо
та владною вас т.к. ми по ви не вигляд
варто ти почав основні принципи
міжнародного порядку і такі тримала
як україна мають праву апарати свою
владну частку ось разу після зустрічі в
номері в україну вилетіла мріяти та
далі який США вікторія нуланд
але думка експерти погляд на глибоку з його
особиста petrenko криво замша до dot каваї
300 для розрізання краю на донбасі
мінську біля води немає з каналу алісу та ден
ще я теж і брюссель та вашингтон будуть
інтенсивніше 6 по накат і україн до
виконання мінських у ось упершись руками
увійди про вибори науку кованих
територіях донбасу через ситуацію з
турбуюся в регіоні ти перебуваєш у них
виборі
за kit for сую піди і також за всі ми
будемо у проти ти в на премку вибір
чого закон зручності intense внизу сина
доповідаються і для швидка
політичного процесу та проведення
виборів україни запитує і поліцейську
місію б е і до контролювати ситуацію
на окупованих територіях хули на
цих умовах можна запитати його ти
місії на веденому в team вичавити експерти
та партнери україни з норманської
четвірки повстанем годинникам стають blige
вступлю до моєї теми харчування